2014's divergent a movie about a
futuristic version of chicago
boasts a bunch of major stars some have
gone
on to break out into stardom while
others have continued
their stellar work just under the radar
let's take a look
at what they're up to today as tris
pryor
divergent central character young
actress shailene woodley
absolutely dazzled fans with her poise
ferocity
and stalwart courage after spending her
life with her family
firmly ensconced within the abnegation
faction
tris is totally unprepared for the
moment when she ends up with a deeply
confusing result
that says she's divergent in an effort
to hide her true nature
tris chooses to join the dauntless
faction jumping head first into a life
of adventure
thrills and bravery after already
appearing in prestige films like 2011's
the descendants and 2013's teen romance
the spectacular now
woodley continued her teen fare streak
after divergent hit the silver screen
2014 saw her star in the young adult
blockbuster
the fault in our stars along with the
divergent sequels
woodley popped up in projects like the
2016 biopic snowden before taking a
break from acting and coming back strong
in 2017 with a role on hbo's smash hit
miniseries
big little lies as assault survivor and
single mother
jane chapman with that woodley firmly
moved into more adult roles
winning accolades across the board she
followed it up with the buzzy survival
film adrift
in 2019 woodley made major news
in february 2021 when she announced her
engagement to superstar quarterback
aaron rodgers
when triss arrives in the dauntless
faction she's tested by tobias for eden
played by theo james an instructor who
is assigned to help new recruits
learn the skills of their chosen group
four is a tough teacher
are you kidding no
what makes you think you can talk to me
but he eventually takes a real liking to
triss
when tris is very nearly forced out of
the dauntless faction
due to her lack of skills four decides
to personally train her
but four isn't everything he appears to
be and ultimately he reveals his
shocking secret
he's actually the son of a strict
abnegation leader himself
this truth leads to a romantic
connection between him
and triss born and raised in england
james was best known for 2012's
underworld awakening
prior to his role in divergent alongside
reprising his role in insurgent and
allegiant
james appeared in the 2016 film the
benefactor
and in the underworld sequel blood wars
which hit movie theaters that same year
in the time since divergent debuted
james has shown up in a variety of
movies
including 2020's archive since 2015
james has also worked as an ambassador
for hugo boss
representing its men's collection of
fragrances
part of triss's struggle in joining the
dauntless faction it comes from having
to leave behind her family
losing her mother natalie who is played
by ashley judd
is an especially wrenching loss but
natalie isn't just a mother doing her
best
in impossible circumstances eventually
natalie reveals something shocking to
triss
she herself is also divergent and was
raised as a dauntless
as a result she understands better than
anybody that tris
is in serious danger by the time she
appeared in divergent
ashley judd was already famous she's
best known for her celebrated roles in a
wide variety of movies like 1995's heat
1996's a time to kill 1999's double
jeopardy
and 2000's where the heart is among many
others since divergent judd has taken on
fewer film roles
showing up in romantic comedies like
2014's
big stone gap and the 2016 barack obama
biopic
barry in 2017 she appeared on the twin
peaks reboot as beverly page
followed by a 2017 role on berlin
station
as bb yates she's also active
politically and socially
supporting a number of worthy causes in
2021 she experienced a serious injury
while researching
endangered bonobos in the congo
thankfully her recovery has gone well
over the course of her childhood in the
abnegation faction
tris enjoys a certain level of privilege
due to the fact that her father
andrew played by tony goldwyn is one of
the faction's leaders
because abnegation is in charge of the
government andrew is especially powerful
as a result he feels particularly
betrayed when triss doesn't choose
abnegation
for fans of scandal it was a true
delight to see goldwyn pop up in
divergent and insurgent
from 2012 to 2018 goldwyn played united
states president fitzgerald fitzgrant
throughout all seven seasons of shonda
rhimes's wonderfully soapy political
drama on abc
goldwyn is also an accomplished director
and stage actor
he's directed four feature films
including 2001's
someone like you 2010's conviction and
has appeared in several off-broadway
plays
and musicals since scandal and divergent
wrapped up
goldwyn has showed up on netflix's 2019
original series chambers alongside uma
thurman
and on hbo's 2020 science fiction epic
lovecraft country the fourth member of
the prior family
caleb pryor played by ansel elgort faces
a similar challenge
as tris does during his evaluation
should he stay with his loved ones and
abnegation
go with his sister daedauntless or seek
his own unique path
ultimately caleb bucks every trend and
chooses erudite alienating himself
from both his sister and his parents
shortly after appearing
as shailene woodley's brother in
divergent al gore shook things up by
reuniting with the actress
for 2014's the fault in our stars
in that film elgor plays augustus waters
the doomed love interest
to woodley's hazel grace elgor also
returned for both insurgent and
allegiant
in 2017 he earned his first major reward
knot
thanks to his starring role in edgar
wright's sleek action flick baby driver
which netted the actor a golden globe
nomination in 2018 he followed up baby
driver with billionaire boys club
and in 2019 he played the leading role
in the goldfinch the highly anticipated
adaptation
of donna tart's novel of the same name
which ended up being a major box office
flop
a violent and strong member of dauntless
who was raised in candor
peter is played by miles teller and is a
dangerous combination
of ruthlessness honesty and brutality
unsurprisingly he defeats trist in
hand-to-hand combat right off the bat
and also viciously attacks anyone who
ranks above him
before he was getting sinister and
divergent teller played opposite woodley
as her love interest
in 2013's the spectacular now alongside
the release of divergent
in 2014 he appeared in damien chazelle's
film
whiplash which earned a number of oscar
nots and a few wins
including one for teller's co-star j.k
simmons
he also appeared in two 2014 romantic
comedies
that awkward moment and two night stand
teller went on to appear in both
insurgent and allegiant as well as other
big budget films
like 2015's fantastic four indie
projects like 2016
get a job in searing dramas like 2017's
thank you
for your service dauntless's leaders
are some of the toughest and bravest
people in divergent's post-apocalyptic
world
this group includes jai courtney's eric
one of the faction's youngest ever
leaders
though eric is a high ranking official
amongst the dauntless
he certainly hasn't made many friends
throughout his tenure
acting unnecessarily cruel towards
trainees taking pleasure from their
failures and pain
and even helping erudite in their evil
mission
within the series courtney went on to
appear an insurgent before his turn as
eric hit the silver screen
courtney had a recurring role on star's
historical action
series spartacus blood and sand that's
not his only small screen success
he's also appeared on the 2017 netflix
reboot
wet hot american summer 10 years later
and 2020's
stateless you've also likely seen
courtney in some of his blockbuster
projects
including 2015's terminator genesis 2016
suicide squad 2019's elita battle angel
and 2020's honest thief
triss only makes a few friends when she
arrives in dauntless luckily they turn
out to be stalwart allies
like zoe kravitz's christina who proves
to be extremely important throughout the
entire series
another dauntless transplant christina
is smart and industrious
but usually suffers in hand-to-hand
combat though she and triss occasionally
butt heads they always team up together
the divergent films were just the start
of a lengthy and fruitful collaboration
between kravitz and woodley
who in 2017 would appear as two of the
leading ladies of hbo's star-studded
miniseries
big little lies kravitz plays a young
yoga teacher
named bonnie whose calm exterior is
shattered by a shocking suburban
murderer
kravitz has appeared in a ton of other
projects as well
including the short-lived 2020 hulu
reboot of high fidelity
which in a modern twist cast her as john
cusack's character rob
renamed robin she also appeared as letty
lestrange in 2018's fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald one of
immortan joe's wives
in 2015's mad max fury road and as the
one and only catwoman in matt reeves
2022 reboot
of the batman film franchise when tris
first takes her personality test and
gets the surprising result that she is
divergent
only one person initially knows about it
dauntless member tori wu
played by maggie q shocked by the result
tori immediately warns tris that being
marked as divergent is extraordinarily
dangerous
they call it divergent
you can't tell anyone about this not
even your parents tori is the first
person to tell tris that those marked
divergent can destroy the entire system
gives her vital information and
ultimately joins her fellow dauntless
in the climactic fight against erudite
during her time in the divergent movies
q also starred in the title role on the
cw's nikita series which ran until 2013
as well as the short-lived 2014 series
stalker on which she had the main role
the actress was also a series regular as
hannah wells on designated survivor
from 2016 to 2019 and has appeared in
recent movies like 2020's fantasy island
2020's death of me in 2021's the protege
she has also explored voice acting most
prominently in the role of wonder woman
on young justice one of the older
leaders of the dauntless faction
makai pfeiffer's max has given all of
his responsibilities to eric
by the time divergent begins despite the
fact that he wanted
four to follow in his footsteps though
max isn't quite as cruel as eric
he's also not an ally to triss or any of
the dauntless rebels
pfeiffer was already a popular actor by
the time he appeared in divergent
and its sequels he is likely best known
for his work with spike lee in 1995's
clockers
and for his six-year stint on the
popular medical series
er over the years pfeiffer has carved
out a solid career
on the small screen appearing on shows
like white collar frequency
and the 2020 hulu original series love
victor
the leader of the erudite faction kate
winslet's jeanine has a dark past
janine also developed the personality
test that helps sort the young people
choosing their new or old factions
i think human nature is the enemy
it's human nature to keep secrets lie to
steal
and i want to eradicate that she's
additionally responsible for something
much more sinister
a mind control serum that the erudite
attempt to use to destroy the dauntless
faction
as most moviegoers know winslet was
already a superstar
when she took on the villainous role of
janine in both divergent and insurgent
winslet is internationally renowned for
her starring roles in huge projects like
1997's titanic
2004's eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind 2008's revolutionary road
and 2008's the reader which won winslet
her first academy award
since divergent winslet has peered and
acclaimed movies like the 2015 biopic
steve jobs the intense 2017 survival
film the mountain between us
and the 2020 romantic drama ammonite
abnegation is supposed to be the
selfless faction but one of its leaders
marcus eaton played by ray stevenson is
an abusive and cruel man
his behavior drives evelyn into the
world without a faction
and four into escaping abnegation in
favor of dauntless
a veteran of both the big and small
screen stevenson was the perfect choice
to portray
the austere inscrutable marcus long
before his work in divergent
stevenson was known for his leading
roles in 2004's king arthur
and the epic hbo series rome he's also
beloved by superhero fans for his turns
as frank castle
better known as the punisher in 2008's
punisher warzone
and volstag an asgardian warrior and one
of thor's dearest friends
in the first three thor films during his
time in the divergent film series
stevenson also showed up on shows like
dexter and black sails
in the movies aftermath the actor has
taken on roles in historical dramas like
medici
the spanish princess and vikings check
out one of our news videos right here
plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite sci-fi gems are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one